the greatest woman spoken word no boy
you know I liked his last video wrong
when almost every single song has
its basis
when rap stars get famous after making
lyrics that are Shameless when a woman
is expected to sleep with a man who
doesn't even know what her name is and
when artists are paid to degrade the
very woman that have made already a
banger video so far yeah this guy was
really good the last time
honestly I love the points they bring up
like how rappers can rap about that
stuff but then someone like Tate who
maybe is uh
he's a lover boy maybe uh we're still
looking he's canceled yeah and then
cardi B is out here admitting people and
then all the artists all they do is we
should register some drill lap drill rap
lyrics you know the thing is too about
all the all this music is when you
listen to it all the time it's it it
gets into your subconscious you know
what I mean of course it does so it's
like it's music it's almost like
programming like they push this junk
music so hard because these people at
the top know what it does to you as a
person isn't that crazy I'm gonna take a
moment to suggest to the whole world
that you just stop and turn on like some
70s soft rock or some like Barry White
The Manhattans you know like listen to
that for a week and you will come all
the way down I'm telling you like
whenever I listen I listen to cardi it's
like you feel different like you you
when you listen to that music you feel
you feel completely different and we
know that and we know that that's why
people listen to like a beat or like
rock music when they want to work out
like white people listen to rock music
when they're working out or like pop
hits because it gets you upbeat if
you're listening to angry music you
listen to Rude music that's who you
become yeah yeah turn on some Carpenters
everybody
yikes they're on a Quran recitation
to the point they are nothing more than
pieces of plastic that we can dispose of
once they are no longer retractive it's
sicken and then sadistic that this
world's become so misogynistic and you
can call me unrealistic but just listen
to the statistics
seven in ten men view porn while over 75
million are addicted 68 7 out of ten
yeah that's not even close but
definitely like nine and a half out of
ten are addicted 68 million requests a
day for pornographic pictures that's
making horror one in four searches
sexually related it's like nobody even
knew she existed until she got naked
degraded and abused over and over again
just to gain millions of views it's a
shame we've subdue to a definition of
beauty which is so misconstrued but it's
empowering for these women to go and do
that according to them they're lost too
it's so stupid they're lost too As we
judge each other's looks off of Facebook
likes Instagram pictures to filter off
what we really look like see we are so
obsessed with our outside we have slowly
lost sight of who we really are
in real life
I mean it's sad to see so many teens
lose their self-esteem looking at these
magazines thinking they have to look
like what they see please you are worth
much more than a 2D image on a screen
you are a living breathing human being
if only you knew what you really mean
just look into your history books and
begin to read of all the girls in the
world who were capable to achieve and
you will surely see with certainty
females like Fatima who opened the first
ever University
the first nurse to perform surgery and
how is
the greatest female scholar in eternity
it's a shame you probably haven't even
heard of these great female prodigies
honestly we don't need to give up our
modesty in order to be successful for
you are worth much more than a commodity
that is sexual you have so much more
potential if only you knew your worth
you could be like the greatest of all
women
to have walked this Earth
like Mary the mother of Jesus chosen by
Allah to be an example for the Believers
a woman who stood strong even when she
was abused falsely accused and ridiculed
for things she'd never ever do so it
didn't really matter when there was
nobody else beside her but she knew if
young girls were truly taught or there
were times when that's what that's what
we were taught but to look up to Mother
Mary up to enough people in history who
really accomplished something and who
were so strong and so solid and kind and
good and now the idols that we have are
a disgrace well it's all intentional you
know because they control who they don't
want you to see and they control who
they want you to see it is and it is it
is at different level at the top level
it's intense functional but like and
then there's the level where it's just
intentional for money right like the
people that are just like hell people
are eating into this I'm going to make
money on it that's fine you know when
they're eating it up the funny thing
about like the porn industry and like
only fans and stuff like that is none of
the guys actually watch any of it or
like you know that's like working at a
McDonald's Factory and then going and
eating the chicken nuggets after you see
how they're being made none of the guys
are into it it's literally just to make
money yeah well they're so you know but
the the audience is tremendous and you
can see there's a whole there's a whole
industry now of helping people to
recover from porn addiction and helping
marriages to recover from one or both of
the
um people in the marriage being addicted
to porn and how it's ruined their
intimacy oh yeah that's that's probably
one of the leading factors of America
this is really sad yeah that's horrible
that God was at razak and her ultimate
provider and she had a trust in him
alone just like Asia the wife of fidon
or woman who was Brave and courageous
stood up for what was right and didn't
let anybody change this this February
we're partnering up with a Navy SEAL
friend of ours Tom Shea host a 21 day
virtual event that you guys can join
with us Tom is going to teach you how to
listen to your mind in a new way and how
to control it so that you can have the
discipline you need to build the life
you want whether it's working out your
relationships your money your spiritual
growth this is a 21 day virtual event
where you get to learn how to kill the
excuses in your head and you get to
learn some discipline and those are
things that's how successful people get
successful best part is when you come in
through us you get a discount on the
enrollment so use code Sunny fast50 to
get 50 off the event you will not regret
it you will be a changed person at the
end of it do not miss this so if you're
interested becoming a reformed human an
absolute animal go to tomshey.com and
use Sunny fast50 for 50 off of this
program a woman who was illness and left
in the face of death
for she gave up the riches of this life
because you know so like ancient history
the women we're just talking about women
here but the women in the Bible the
women in the Quran like these were women
who were just solid and classy and now
we have so few examples of that you know
I don't get like I don't get Star Struck
I'm not big into celebrities but you do
know that I have like a mad like the one
celeb celebrity I say I'm into is Kate
Middleton who's you know I don't even
know who that is okay she's she's Prince
William's wife so he's the next he's
he's in line to be the king the next
king after his father dies the king of
England and she is so classy and so
beautiful and she dresses like a dream
and no matter what [__] hits the
royal family she just keeps her chin up
and Carries On like a lady and I will
never be the lady that she is but I love
to look at her and think if I can be a
one millionth of the lady that she is
that's who I want want to be and I would
love to teach little girls to you know
look up to somebody like that not a
woman that's squatting and urinating on
stage to be provocative yeah that's
disgusting it's disgusting and it's sad
and it leaves people empty anyway I bet
Kate Middleton's Gonna Save Us but she's
a step in the right direction yeah
go ahead next up the mother of the
Believers a wealthy Merchant who had
nurtured the prophet for over 25 years
his first wife the love of his life and
the mother of his kids she was the first
to believe in him when nobody else ever
did she just is
Beyond any words that can make you
understand so much so that even Allah
sent her his salaam she was Grand and
Allah assured her just like her daughter
Fatima the master of all women in
Paradise a woman who would shine so
bright she was nicknamed as Zara The
Splendid one with the most generous of
Hearts a woman who gave up so much of a
food she had no choice but to fast she
would fight on behalf of her father even
as a little girl
and such the examples of the greatest
woman in the entire
and it had nothing to do with how they
looked but for who they truly were
so ignore the standard of success
defined by society when God has said
that the best of mankind are those who
have piety regardless of your shape your
color or your race for God does not look
at your bodies nor does he look at your
face rather he looks towards your heart
and checks your faith so at the end of
the day it doesn't matter what the
people say or who they think you are
when you could be like the greatest of
all women
in the eyes of Allah
yo those Graphics are really fire too
huh it's very interesting what do you
think about women wearing hijabs too so
I never understood it and then I I
learned a fact about
um let's just say 2 000 years ago you
know around when Jesus was coming around
so the women I know this for is true for
the Jews the reason that women covered
their hair was to because they
understood that men were like always
looking wait and were attracted so women
were very modest clothing that went
straight down so they couldn't see
curves and things the way their skin the
way they do now so a woman's hair was
the thing that would tempt a man so to
speak uh and catch his eye so they
covered their hair in as a just a way to
avoid but yes between the Sexes
basically and a way to keep women
protected from unscrupulous men the eye
so when I think of it that way it was a
way to protect them it wasn't a way to
oppress them the way that we're told
today that a woman covering our hair is
to oppress her when it really is just to
protect her from the eyes of
unscrupulous men and I and you know and
it doesn't once I heard that and I
understood it I was like okay I get that
now and then and I understand that and I
appreciate it you know again having it
mandated as an American woman is a thing
that I'm like not into mandates on
anything but if women choose that and
they choose to keep themselves modest to
prevent [__] that happens between
men and women because not all men are
going to be wonderful and that's just
the reality and it and people suck we
all do so I'm cool with that yeah it's
definitely really interesting because
they knew at the time that um a big part
of women's values and their beauty so
it's like almost how you know women
covering up their their hair and
protecting their body from what you know
would ultimately be a threat like what
would be the reason that people would be
a threat to them because they would come
after them for that reason well it's
it's it's it's similar to how like as a
man you get you gotta like hide your
money and stuff like that you don't just
walk around with you know big chains in
a bad area does that make sense or am I
tripping it doesn't I'm caught up on you
saying that you know they understood
that value was in Beauty and I don't
know that that's necessarily true but
it was definitely it was definitely to
prevent Temptation and to prevent men
from having to deal with temptation of
of a woman's beautiful okay women's
women's beauty is very valuable is that
a better way to put it no I I just this
whole value uh thing is is tripping me
up attraction I'm just thinking more
about just Temptation and attraction
more so because I don't even think it
goes as deep as value General attraction
and you know wanting to like touch
something that's shiny and beautiful I
don't think people are thinking in terms
of value I think it's more basic than
that at the end of the day it's a means
to protect women yeah not control them
yeah yes I would like somebody to
explain to me though why some women have
to wear the like Muslim women have to
wear the whole face covering with just
the eyes coming out like I don't get
that [__] at all I don't understand is
there a good reason for it what's the
reason for it I'd like to at least hear
it so I can react to it but I don't know
do you know no I think it's just a
preference thing to be honest but I'm
not 100 yeah no truly have no idea and
and to me that just seems like really
uncomfortable and inconvenient and I
also really think that a person's face
is a big part of their expression in
this world I don't think that we all
need to run around you know shaking our
our junk all over in front of everybody
but I think that a face a smile an
expression is how we part a big part of
how we communicate yeah that's why so I
don't get it and I'd be curious to see
you know I'd have a respectful ear for
whatever explanation there is on that
yeah that was a big thing with kovid
like wearing masks everywhere it like it
it got rid of like that um I don't know
that connection with other people
everything just felt like you're
interacting with robots and you know the
people that still wear masks are robots
and PCs I'm sorry I didn't mean to throw
my hoodie at no you did you actually
definitely meant to throw your hoodie on
the Sleeping Dog and interrupt him he
was sleeping very nice yeah
fancy has not made an appearance on this
channel in a very long time
pick him up here he comes here he comes
oh my God my favorite this is the best
one in the house this is the best
creature in the house okay you need your
hands
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure to like subscribe join my Discord
if you want a free preview of how I've
generated over five million dollars at
age 19. totally free preview if you join
and I'll see you later hope you guys
like the video
[Music]